you're looking for a job right now
resorts world is hiring the resort
launched a new career website today
as it prepares for its grand opening
next year our hector mejia has more now
on the new postings
as construction right behind me gets
closer and closer to completion
resorts world is now recruiting they are
looking to fill
6 000 positions by the time they open
in the summer the resort is adding 3 500
rooms on the las vegas strip
monday the company launched a new
website rwlvcareers.com
their candidates can now start looking
at positions that are available
we are told that interview timelines and
start dates will vary
depending on the jobs and they range
from entry to management
level in multiple departments the latest
openings we found are for database
engineers
marketing financial planning and
hospitality
then on monday november 30th the company
will begin
conducting live 30 minute sessions
online
to answer any questions about the hiring
process
candidates must register them and here's
something interesting the company says
what you see here is one of the largest
hotel construction sites in the u.s
at a cost of more than 4 billion dollars
resorts world is said to be
the most expensive resort property ever
developed here
in las vegas reporting on the strip
hector mejia
8 news now good stuff all right thank
you hector and you can find a full list
of job opportunities on our website
8newsnow.com
just click job board it's right under
the community tab on our home page